the david pakman show subreddit a top
destination for viewers and listeners of
the show to respectfully discuss
political ideas at david pakman.com
slash reddit has surpassed 13,000
subscribers one of the largest
progressive media subreddits period i
don't think i have to qualify it in any
further way interesting post from a
recent interview i did i was recently
interviewed on an interesting a show
called startups hosted by entrepreneur
dance Altman and streamer Stephen
destiny bunnell and we talked about the
future of the David Pakman show on
twitch and yes I mean we're not for
people who are worried that we're moving
over to twitch and abandoning anything
we are not we're not abandoning YouTube
we're not abandoning the podcast we're
still as committed as ever to those
platforms but my view is always
diversify platforms and revenue streams
in order to reduce reliance on any
particular one would have surfaced well
during ad pocalypse 2017 so we are
increasingly publishing more and
streaming more on twitch and make sure
you're following me there at twitch TV
slash David Pakman if you have Amazon
Prime you can subscribe for free with
twitch Prime it's a paid subscription
for us but it costs you nothing someone
also noticing and putting together a
funny meme that Sam Harris started
following me on Twitter that's true I
have no idea why I've had no contact
with Sam about it I don't know anything
about it other than I noticed Sam Harris
is now following me on Twitter and maybe
something will at some point come of it
and then also increasingly there are
posts and memes and images about people
calling in during live calls and I don't
pick up on them here's one called when
David doesn't choose your call this is I
I don't really know how to deal with
this when we take live calls now we
often get 70 80 or even sometimes close
to a hundred people that are holding it
once and usually I take you know 10 to
12 calls at a time I don't really know
what I can do in terms of making it so a
lot of people don't sit on hold and are
never able to get on people have had the
idea of
capping the capping the phone line queue
at twenty people for example but the
problem is there's a lot of really
frequent callers and I try to go to new
people we keep notes about like when did
I last pick up on someone and if I
picked up on someone three days prior
and I have fifty other people who I've
never talked to I'm gonna prioritize the
people I've never talked to just to make
sure that we're not always talking to
the same people so limiting the queue to
20 is problematic because 20 people that
regularly call might be in the queue so
I don't know how to deal with that I
understand the frustration of people not
being able to get on but it is something
that we're working on ideas as always
very very much welcome make sure you are
subscribed to the subreddit it's a great
place to suggest ideas for the show chat
with other viewers and listeners david
pakman.com slash